A SHIFTING TIMELINE ON HIS
MEETING WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
DICTATOR KIM DRONE ON.
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION ARE
BEGINNING TO MAKE WATERGATE LOOK
LIKE CHILD'S PLAY.
THE REVELATIONS OF THE OBAMA ERA
POLITICAL TARGETING GROW MORE
OMINOUS BY THE DAY.
THE FBI IS UNDER INCREASING
PRESSURE TONIGHT TO EXPLAIN WHY
IT WAS SURVEILLING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AS THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
CONTACTED BY INFORMANTS
CONTINUES TO INCREASE.
SAM CLOVIS, GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS
AND CARTER PAGE WERE TARGETED.
THE LETTER RESPONDING LAST NIGHT
ON THE "ANGLE."
THE PERSON I WAS SPEAKING WITH
WHO IS A UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR AT
CAMBRIDGE IN THE U.K. AT THE
TIME.
I WAS INVITED TO PARTICIPATE IN
A CONFERENCE IN JULY OF 2016 AND
EVERYTHING SEEMED TOTALLY NORMAL
EVERYTHING SEEMED TOTALLY NORMA
NORMAL.
>> Laura: IT'S CALLED
GROOMING, THAT'S WHAT THEY DO,
CARTER.
BUT A MUCH MORE INCENDIARY CLAIM
WAS MADE BY ONE OF OUR OTHER
GUESTS.
FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISOR
MICHAEL CAVUTO TOLD ME LAST
NIGHT THAT HE KNOWS FOR A FACT
THAT THERE WERE MORE THAN ONE
INFORMANT TARGETING TRUMP TEAM
MEMBERS BECAUSE HE WAS ONE OF
THOSE TARGETS.
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING
THAT I KNOW FOR A FACT.
THIS INFORMANT, THIS PERSON THAT
THEY PLANTED, TRY TO PLANT INTO
THE CAMPAIGN AND EVEN INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION IF YOU BELIEVE
AXIOS, HE'S NOT THE ONLY PERSON
THAT CAME WITH THE CAMPAIGN AND
THE FBI IS NOT THE ONLY OBAMA
AGENCY THAT CAME WITH THE
CAMPAIGN.
I KNOW BECAUSE THEY CAME AT ME.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT
RESPONDED TO THE INTRIGUE TODAY.
>> IF THEY HAD SPIES IN MY
CAMPAIGN THAT WOULD BE A
DISGRACE TO THIS COUNTRY.
INSULTS THAT ANYONE HAS EVER
SEEN.
THAT WOULD BE VERY ILLEGAL ASIDE
FROM EVERYTHING ELSE.
IT WOULD MAKE PROBABLY EVERY
POLITICAL EVENT EVER LOOK LIKE
SMALL POTATOES.
THAT WOULD BE UNPRECEDENTED IN
THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: CAVUTO ADVANCED HIS
CLAIM EARLIER ON FOX CLAIMING
THAT SOMEONE, A SHADOWY FIGURE
FLOATED THE IDEA OF PASSING
ALONG EMAILS RELATED TO
HILLARY CLINTON TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, YOU RAISED
THIS ISSUE WITH MUELLER'S TEAM
WHEN THEY WERE QUESTIONING YOU.
AND THEY DID NOTHING?
>> THEY WEREN'T EVEN INTERESTED.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN SEEM TO BE
TAKING NOTES.
I OFFERED THEM THE TIMELINE.
>> Laura: WE AT "THE INGRAHAM
ANGLE" ALONG WITH A DOJ PRODUCER
AT FOX LOOKED INTO THESE CLAIMS
AND HAVE IDENTIFIED THE FIGURE
IN QUESTION.
OUR SOURCE CORROBORATED SOME OF
CAVUTO'S CLAIMS BUT HE DENIED
TRYING TO ENTRAP CAVUTO AND HIS
ASSOCIATES.
HE FURTHER INSISTED THAT HE DID
NOT WORK FOR ANY INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY.
FBI'S TARGETING OF INFORMAL OR
LOW LEVEL TRUMP ASSOCIATES TO
GET DIRT ON HIGHER-UPS WAS
SOMETHING OF A TREND, PERHAPS A
DANGEROUS ONE DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
LET'S TURN TO NEWT GINGRICH TO
REACT TO THE LATEST REVELATIONS
ABOUT THE DEEP STATE'S MISDEEDS.
MR. SPEAKER, IT IS GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
MY GOODNESS, THIS IS WILD.
YOU HAVE THIS PERSON, A
PROFESSOR IN ENGLAND WHO IS
MAKING THESE CONTACTS WITH
VARIOUS MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
TEAM, THROWING THE WHOLE TIME
LINE INTO.
ORIGINALLY WE HEARD FROM COMEY
THAT THE INVESTIGATION REALLY
BEGAN ON JULY 31ST, NOW IT LOOKS
LIKE THIS PARTICULAR INFORMANT,
SPY, MOLE, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL HIM, MET WITH CARTER PAGE
IN EARLY JULY.
>> IT ALL KEEPS GETTING MORE AND
MORE OPEN.
PRESENTLY, REMEMBER THERE WAS A
REFERENCE AT ONE POINT VERY
EARLY ON TO SENIOR OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION PEOPLE BEING
BRIEFED.
PRESENTLY SOMEONE WILL FIGURE
OUT TO ASK WHAT DID VALERIE
JARRETT KNOW AND WHEN DID SHE
KNOW WHAT YOU MAX ME WHEN I
ASKED THAT LAST NIGHT ON THE
"ANGLE."
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ON TARGET.
WHAT DID BARACK OBAMA KNOW AND
WHEN DID HE KNOW WHAT?
BECAUSE WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
HAPPENED IS ON EVERY SINGLE
LEVEL, AND THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
WITH REALLY BIG SCANDALS, THEY
KEEP UNFOLDING AND THEY KEEP
UNFOLDING AND THEY KEEP
UNFOLDING.
SO WE ARE NOW SUPPOSED TO
BELIEVE THAT THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE WAS LYING
TO US, THE HEAD OF THE CENTRAL
INTELLIGENCE
INTELLIGENCE                   C
INTELLIGENCE                   N
INTELLIGENCE                   R
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY WAS LYING TO
US, THE HEAD OF THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION WAS
LYING TO US.
THE NUMBER TWO PERSON IN THE FBI
WAS LYING TO US.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS LYING
TO US.
SHE WAS MEETING WITH
BILL CLINTON ON AN AIRPLANE IN
PRIVATE TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN.
AT WHAT POINT DO YOU JUST SAY
GIVE ME A BREAK?
AND ALL OF THIS I BELIEVE WAS
BEING COORDINATED BY OBAMA AND
BY VALERIE JARRETT.
>> Laura: YOU WILL WRITE TO
OBAMA ON THIS.
YOU THINK IT'S INCONCEIVABLE
THAT THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE COUNTRY WAS NOT TOLD THAT
THEY HAD SEEN THIS CARTER PAGE
ON THE LIST OF THE FOREIGN
POLICY ADVISORS AND THEY DECIDED
TO GO INTO OVERDRIVE?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE -- LOOK AT
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF THINGS GOING
ON.
I DON'T BELIEVE THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT WAS A
TIGHTLY CENTRALIZED AS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, YOU COULD HAVE
HAD AS MANY DIFFERENT THINGS
GOING ON, ALL OF THEM ARE
ILLEGAL WITHOUT THE PRESIDENT
HAVING BEEN BRIEFED.
FURTHERMORE, AN EXAMPLE.
THE PRESIDENT IS EMAILING
HILLARY CLINTON ON HER INSECURE
EMAIL.
THEY CAREFULLY REWORD THE FBI
REPORT TO AVOID TELLING US THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA CLEARLY HAD TO
KNOW SHE WAS USING AN ILLEGAL
EMAIL BECAUSE HE'S WRITING TO IT
EMAIL BECAUSE HE'S WRITING TO I
IT.
>> Laura: SUSAN RICE SAID
PRESIDENT OBAMA DID EVERYTHING
BY THE BOOK.
REMEMBER SHE WROTE THAT EMAIL TO
HERSELF, I HAVE TO MENTION IT IN
EVERY SHOW.
THIS IS WHAT JIM CLAPPER SAID
TODAY ON THE VIEW ABOUT WHETHER
SPYING REALLY OCCURRED.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WAS THE FBI SPYING ON TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN?
>> THEY WERE NOT.
THEY WERE SPYING -- A TERM I
DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE -- ON
WHAT THE RUSSIANS WERE DOING,
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
RUSSIANS INFILTRATING, TRYING TO
GAIN ACCESS, TRYING TO GAIN
LEVERAGE?
>> Laura: IF THE RUSSIANS ARE
PULLING THE STRINGS.
>> I'VE KNOWN JIM KLAPPER FOR
YEARS.
I AM ASTOUNDED HOW BAD HE LOOKS
NOW.
I'M ASTOUNDED HOW DISHONEST AND
INCOMPETENT HE LOOKS.
HE WAS A GREAT PUBLIC SERVANT
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
BUT WHEN THE DIRECTOR -- FORMER
DIRECTOR OF INTELLIGENCE TELLS
YOU HE DOESN'T LIKE TO USE THE
WORD SPYING YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF --    --
>> Laura: THAT IS FUNNY.
I DIDN'T THINK OF THAT.
>> HE WAS THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HE WAS IN
CHARGE OF DOING?
HE WAS IN CHARGE OF SPYING.
AND THIS WHOLE THING IS JUST --
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT, I THINK WHAT
HAPPENED WAS PEOPLE LIKE CLAPPER
AND FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL INTELLIGENCE AGENCY, ALL
THESE GUYS THOUGHT THEY COULD
GET AWAY WITH THIS BECAUSE
HILLARY WAS GOING TO WIN.
AND WHEN HILLARY WON THE FIX
WOULD BE IN, EVERYTHING WOULD BE
COVERED UP AND AROUND 10:00 ON
ELECTION NIGHT THEY ALL BEGAN TO
REALIZE THIS COULD GET REALLY
BAD AND THEY WERE SHIFTING GEARS
FROM PROTECTING HILLARY, WHICH
HAD BEEN THEIR JOB FOR TWO
YEARS, TO TRYING TO DESTROY
TRUMP AND NOW YOU ARE WATCHING
PEOPLE WHO I THINK IN EVERY CASE
ARE IN DANGER OF GOING TO JAIL.
IF THE SYSTEM WORKS AND PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY TESTED ON DID YOU
TELL THE TRUTH UNDER OATH AND
THEN VIPER IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE.
>> Laura: HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THAT BIG MOMENT WHERE HE DIDN'T
TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT THE
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM.
HE ADDRESSED THIS TODAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS CALLING ME A
LYING MACHINE.
OKAY.
WHAT THAT STEMS FROM AS AN
EXCHANGE I HAD WITH A SENATOR
FIVE YEARS AGO IN MARCH OF 2013
ABOUT A SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM AND
HE WAS ASKING ME ABOUT ONE AND I
WAS THINKING ABOUT ANOTHER.
SO I MADE A MISTAKE, BUT I
DIDN'T LIE.
>> WHAT YOU ARE REFERENCING IS
THAT WHEN YOU SAID -- WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING BUT JAMES SNOWDEN
BLOWING THE WHISTLE ON THE NSA
ILLEGALLY SPYING INTO THOUSAND
13 WHEN YOU WERE ASKED ABOUT YOU
SAID NO.
THAT IS A LIE.
I'M SORRY.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO BUY A
VOWEL.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
>> I HOPE GENERAL FLYNN WATCHED
THAT AND I HOPE GENERAL FLYNN IS
PREPARED TO GO BACK.
OBVIOUSLY THE CLAPPER DEFENSE,
WHATEVER YOU THOUGHT I SAID I
DIDN'T MEAN TO SAY AND IT WASN'T
WHAT I SAID I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU
THOUGHT I SET IT BECAUSE I
WOULDN'T HAVE SET IT IF I HAD
KNOWN YOU THOUGHT I SAID IT AND
THEREFORE CAN'T REALLY BE A
PROBLEM.
THIS TELLS YOU HOW PATHETIC THIS
IS GOING TO BE.
>> Laura: THIS IS THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
THESE ARE LIKE THE MOST
IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN OUR
INTELLIGENCE -- YOU SAY HE SUCH
A CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL.
HE SOUNDS LIKE A BUMBLING IDIOT.
SORRY I'M BEING CRUEL HERE I
GUESS.
THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING IS A
MAN WHO WAS A GREAT PROFESSIONAL
WHO IS NOW IN A TOTALLY
IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION.
TO GET OFF TELEVISION
DESPERATELY TRYING TO EXPLAIN